MALE SPEAKER: So when you look
down at that then, that's like
an X.
MATT PARKER: It is.
It's one of my ex-favorite
numbers.
For a while, my favorite
number was 3,435.
And I say for a while, because
I don't think a favorite
number -- you don't commit
to a favorite number
for life, to be honest.
Very few things that I'll have a
static opinion on what is my
favorite, other than
my girlfriend.
Whereas 3,435 for a
while there was
one of my top numbers.
I'll show you why.
And actually, it probably had a
bit of a record run as being
my favorite number.
3,435, it's called a
Munchausen number.
And what you do for a Munchausen
number is you raise
each of the digits to the
power of that digit.
So 3 to the 3 plus 4 to
the 4 plus 3 to the 3
plus 5 to the 5.
And if you then add 3 to the 3
plus 4 to the 4 plus 3 to the
3, plus 5 to the 5,
it equals 3,435.
It equals itself.
It's a bit like a narcissistic
number, which I'm sure people
will be talking about.
Except this time, each number
is obsessed with itself.
In fact, the Munchausen
it's named after was a
narcissistic character.
And so it's a very, very
narcissistic number.
And what's even better about
it is it's the only one.
In base 10, this is
the only number
which has that property.
Well, it was the only number
that has that property.
If you look up online, whenever
you talk about the
Munchausen number and you talk
about 3,435, someone will come
along and say, but what about
438,579,088, huh?
What about that?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I was
just about to say that.
MATT PARKER: It was on the tip
of your tongue, wasn't it?
Because 4 to the 4 plus 3 to the
3 plus 8 to the 8 plus 5
to the 5 plus 7 to the 7 plus
9 to the 9 plus 0 to the 0
plus 8 to the 8 plus 8 to the
8 equals 438,579,088.
And people are all up in your
grill with what up with this?
And there is a problem
with that.
There's a reason why that makes
me emotional, and I'll
show you why.
It is this bit here--
0 to the 0.
This relies on 0 to
the 0 equaling 0.
And it turns out 0 to the
0 does not equal 0.
Nor does it equal 1,
for that matter.
0 to the 0 is undefined.
There is no value for 0 to the
0, because anything to
the 0 equals 1.
And 0 to the anything
equals 0.
And when both of those things
happen at once, you basically
have a big argument, and people
get very emotional
about this.
If you want to find equally core
numbers, there are things
like 4,155, which equals the
digits at the bottom--
4,155 to the power of the same
digits, but not necessarily in
the same order.
So if you put them up as in 5,
4, 1, 5, that still holds.
But you've got to shuffle the
digits around when you raise
them up the top.
MALE SPEAKER: You mentioned to
me that was your favorite
number for a long time.
MATT PARKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: It was your
favorite number for possibly a
record time.
MATT PARKER: It must have
been seven or eight
months it was up there.
It was good.
MALE SPEAKER: What happened?
Why did you break up?
MATT PARKER: It was
fun, but it just--
I got bored.
And I went back to the safety
of narcissistic
numbers for a while.
So 371 took over for a
substantial period of time.
And then I wanted to go
back into perfect
numbers for a while.
So 33,550,336 took back over.
And at the moment, it's 764.
But that's because it's
a grafting number.
But this is not the time nor
the place to talk about
grafting numbers.